I think that we as a global collective
owe mr. gyro zeppeli a great debt of
gratitude for making grills fashionable
again in fact immediately after
finishing steel ball run I went out and
got some of my own and now every single
time I smile I am actively encouraging
you to subscribe to the new alter view
for regular Jojo content uploaded
straight until YouTube feeds so just
push my teeths and you're in hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today I'm back to Jojo on a Monday
which may not become known as Jojo
Mondays but we are here once more white
specifically to discuss the ever
brilliant steel ball run because I'd
like to delve into quite possibly my
single favorite character within the
entire Jojo saga being gyro zeppeli so
from everything I've anecdotally
experienced or miss Jojo journey gyro
seems like a pretty popular dude and
they can very much see why because his
presence is absolutely integral in
starting the new Jojo universe on a high
and providing us with a very different
character to initially latch on to
but gyro also remains consistently
captivating throughout the entirety of
part 7 even when the whole corpse part
business heads into full swing and we
somewhat lose sight of the race in favor
of stopping mr. president
but Jiro had me from the get-go in what
I would describe as a perfect
introduction in which after a solid
breakdown of the world and its premise
we land on this incredibly bold
character design that is sure to be
initially divisive because you know
that's just what personalized golden
grills are going to do but in terms of
aesthetics alone gyro immediately stands
apart from everything we've seen in this
world thus far which portrays itself as
something of a standard Western however
then in struts gyro with his primarily
purple color palette and it makes you
pay attention because there has been
such minimal use of color thus far and
Shino makes a lot of sense given that
purple was a very difficult color to
produce back in the eld days meaning
that it was only donned by the somewhat
wealthy and to contrast it you also have
some dabs of green and the atomic blonde
hair that just resulted in this solid
aesthetic binding and for this I suppose
I have to give quite a bit of credit to
the JoJo's coloured adventure team for
selecting this palette from the wide
variety of options that are key himself
concocted in addition to this though it
is immediately made clear that gyro is
not someone to be messed around with
which is an essential classic western
cowboy trait the whole strolling into a
new town getting into trouble with some
random ruffian and then immediately
displaying your immense skill classic
rogue age
sort of stuff there and I really do
enjoy that he went to the trouble of
stating that he was not a nice guy
because that immediately lets us know
that we are in for a morally ambiguous
ride with this gent at the helm and I
was all for that but at the same time
it's clear that gyro isn't too complete
dick dick is following this when he
encounters Johnny he's actually
strangely kind to our Jojo of this part
and even issues him with the challenge
that would go on to change his life so
it's our first non aesthetic indicator
there is a lot more depth to gyro then
his tough-guy exterior would lead us to
believe and I mean of course he does go
about this in a Rama and agonistic way
but it is immediately obvious that he
was treating Johnny very differently
than his previous encounter just with
something of a tough-love approach and
after this encounter johnny has a nice
narrator like monologue but he describes
the situation as the summer of 1890 the
only thing I could say there was a
beauty that existed on that Beach a
beauty within the darkness and I was
drawn to something on this Beach will
there be a light cult hope here and then
of course he immediately answers his own
question by resolving to ride once more
and to follow gyro into the depths of
Steel Bull Run but Johnny also in my
opinion very accurately perceives jairos
existence in this soliloquy moment
because he would go on to be a shining
ray of beauty in this very cruel and
dark world so despite the aesthetic
brightness of an Old West setting gyro
narrative Lee was kind of like our sole
source of light in a gloomy and
impossibly long tunnel and just like
Johnny we needed to stick to him if we
wanted to have any hope of coming out of
this in a good spot and of course every
positive feeling towards gyro in the
world is then solidified when we see him
pack his teddy with him go on the race
which honestly I can pinpoint as the
exact moment that I knew I was going to
love everything about driver and this is
all just his introduction but really at
this stage what didn't he have going for
him he had a great design and intriguing
competitive style a capability to engage
in weird quirky humor and some sort of
vaguely defined moral compass that was
going to lead his magnificent charge in
this race and you know something that I
find very interesting to think about in
retrospect is the fact that gyro is one
of if not probably the most morally
upstanding individual in this series
which becomes very clear over the course
of his multiple flashbacks where we see
him being raised as an executioner and
struggling with the age-old question of
well questioning things there's also
something that Johnny said about 1/3 of
the way through the series that had
always stuck with me in which he claimed
that gyro didn't have that raw selfish
hunger the
was necessary to overcome someone like
dear for example and to be clear in that
context I believe that Johnny was
hitting on the fact that Jarrah had been
born of nobility and had never had to
truly struggle to achieve anything which
left him incapable of pushing himself to
his true limits however at the time I
also took it to mean that unlike almost
every other competitor of the steel ball
run race gyro was not seeking victory
for his own sake which would turn out to
be very very true as all of his efforts
were for the sake of effectively saving
the life of one boy back kenapa Lee and
yes it is bigger than the life of just
one child because it also acts as a
grand statement of Jireh wanting to
choose his own path in life rather than
inheriting the strict role of the
zeppole family but everything explored
in Jerez past speaks to a much higher
moral standard than almost any other
primary character of Stillwell run even
Johnny and in fact especially Johnny and
this definitely is not to say the gyro
was some sort of perfect upstanding
morally righteous individual because as
we established in his introduction he
certainly isn't and that is very
important as well because the moments
where he does choose to be an absolute
prick of what gives him that much
desired depth because it results in the
impression that he is a complicated
fellow and subscribes purely to his own
point of view of the world and sometimes
that's not going to match our personal
moral compasses as readers but it's a
very admirable and even enviable trait
for a character to have because I like
the sense that for better or worse gyro
is unwilling to compromise himself and
sometimes that results in great good and
sometimes it results in not so good but
I think that this is going to bring us
to another core feature of the appeal
regarding gyro which is specifically his
relationship with one Johnny Joestar
because if like I said gyro is the kind
of person who is averse to compromising
himself and Johnny would be the exact
opposite because he does clearly possess
that selfish hunger that he claims to be
absent in gyro and as a result these two
play off each other pretty fantastically
because it's tempting to think about
them as a perfect duo and I guess in
many ways you could make the argument
that yeah they are but in the end
they're just such different people who
each have their fantastic qualities as
well as their incredibly detrimental
ones and almost none of those qualities
are aligned either so for example
Johnny's journey through the series
starts at a place where he has a supreme
lack of belief in himself and his own
abilities then when that gets meshed up
against driver who has a supreme sense
of his own abilities while the way in
which those two opposite personalities
interact has the effect of leading to
some tremendous growth of Johnny and
that's also true for Shiro as
and some other aspects of character so
these two have something of a symbiotic
relationship managing to impart great
benefits on to one another whilst also
using their strengths to make up for the
weaknesses of the other plus our key
also takes the time to slow down the
pace of steel ball run a lot and often
dwells on some of the more mundane
interactions between gyro and Johnny the
obvious ones being whenever gyro tries
out a new gag on him
Lille infamous pizza mozzarella song
which only has the effect of enhancing
the likeability of both Johnny and Rara
and in my case primarily driver although
quite probably one of my favorite
aspects regarding gyro is that this late
in the judger process being in pot seven
and all he is not a stand user and I
can't even begin to explain just how
thrilled I was when I realized that he
fought pretty much exclusively using the
spin techniques because over the course
of parts 3 through part 6 I was really
beginning to get a bit tired of the fact
that it seems like you were only
actually relevant in this series if you
had a stand so watching gyro take on
enemies without his own stand and
actually seeing him defeat stand users
was quite an incredible and unique tojo
experience because it really doesn't
happen all that much elsewhere and even
looking as deep into part eight as we
are that has kind of turned into more of
a standard model of power focus so gyro
is an incredibly unique case in the post
jamon error of Jojo and I mentioned this
in my steel ball run review the quite
possibly the crowning moment of this was
his fight against ringer in the true
man's world section of story which you
know featured a stand user of not
insignificant power given that Ringo
could rewind time and they feel like in
any previous and probably future part
this would have been impossible to
defeat without the stand of one's own
however in part seven gyro is able to
very cleverly dissect disability as well
as ring goes most likely actions and
then just go on to completely outplay
him like it was a chess match and that
sort of stuff is on despite quite often
with gyro because yeah his spin
technique is powerful but he comes up
against a lot of absolutely crazy crap
in the form of stance and it more often
than not becomes more of a mental battle
than a physical one and I guess be fair
Jojo fights and later pants have always
been kind of like that where it comes
down to who implements their stand in
the most creative and efficient way but
I don't know it was just refreshing to
see a non stand user step into this
world and completely wreck face it just
gives me a whole different level of
respect for gyro then I would give to
any stand user because this guy is
strolling into a world where he simply
does not belong and he should be
completely outclassed by the various
bizarre powers and that's great because
it also makes
something of a permanent underdog in the
series and how can one not of that but
of course no discussion regarding gyro
would be complete without delving into
his final moments of Steel bull run and
you know that at this point I've been
involved in this old George or thing for
six parts and I knew to expect tragedy
at the tail end of a series but still
the Sydney pretty damn hard firstly
because his final moments were nothing
short of incredible pushing himself to
perform his most impressive technique
yet to the ballbreaker which would
appear to be gyro developing something
of a stand but I have also been told the
ballbreaker is the stand of the steel
ball itself but whatever case gyro
unlocked and made use of it which after
all of my praise for him not being a
stand user you'd think that I would be
against but the fact that he used it at
the end of his life is the perfect way
to implement something like this and it
continues to display his profound
potential you know even threatening to
tear down the dimensional madness of d4c
basically it was a glorious loss stand
by gyro and the montage of flashbacks
from Johnny really solidifies his
character and immediately bestows Johnny
with gyros inherited well which we would
take into the finale of the series and
that kind of is the depressing
perfection of a character like gyro he
is an existence that is almost too good
to serve as the main protagonist because
he has himself more or less sorted out
and as a result from a narrative
standpoint the only thing left for him
to do is to contribute to the growth of
another character in this case being
Johnny which is achieved through one
final lesson and then his death which
forever changes and elevates Johnny and
this is what I feared what happened to
Jireh from the very beginning because
it's always a more gut wrenching
experience to kill a character like him
then it would have been to go the other
way around and have Johnny make the
sacrifice everything I've mentioned in
this video thus far made gyro a
supremely likable and admirable
character and according to the rules of
tragedy which Jojo by-and-large
absolutely subscribes to there was only
ever going to be one appropriate finale
for this larger-than-life figure and so
gyro did just that completing a
phenomenal character arc as well as
becoming the commanding presence of part
seven and for the last few remaining
chapters it really did feel like we were
missing something very very important
which is indicative of just how much of
this series gyro carried on his
shoulders which isn't to say that he was
the reason for part sevens brilliance
because it was very much a solid
all-around experience and whether at the
center of all of that his gyro you very
much acts as the heart and soul of steel
boar run but what do you guys think
please do let me know in the comments
down below well
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more Georgia content and
please do check out some of my other
videos we'll even subscribe to the
channel for regular Jojo Wanda to live
it straight to your YouTube feed but for
now this has been the new ultra view and
I'll see you next time